[Musica]
il 18 dicembre
1983 aveva cinque anni ero al mio terzo
anno di asilo
al resoconto al primo trimestre la mia
maestra Miss Brooks scrisse che stava
avendo un ottimo periodo perché ero in
grande forma
puntualizzava anche però che aveva avuto
un periodo molto brutto a novembre
bullizzando e spaventando i miei
compagni
queste generiche affermazioni
sottintendevano minacce pugni in faccia
furti di giocattoli e anche rapimenti di
orsetti di peluche
Il 16 maggio 1987 la data riportata sul
primo dei miei numerosi romanzi
incompiuti
un annetto dopo fermo a un semaforo con
mia mamma ricordo che era un giorno di
pioggia le domande in caso finissi il
libro se avrebbe permesso che lo
pubblicassi
lei scoppiò a ridere per mia fortuna
Il 2 giugno 1989 era un venerdì
Mi trovai davanti a una
grigiastra psicologa in quello che
ricordo come un appartamento tetro
immerso Nella penombra
sostenevo da una settimana di aver perso
la memoria
cadendo continuamente inciampi e
convincendo chi mi circondava per altro
giustamente che stavo fingendo
la dottoressa dopo aver fatto qualche
esercizio con dei blocchi di legno e
delle figure geometriche
alzò un blocchetto di schede
disse che mi avrebbe mostrato delle
macchie che dovevo dirle che cosa ci
scorgevo dentro
no
pensai tutto eccitato Come nei film
quando però la dottoressa sollevò la
prima scheda ciò che scorsi nella
macchina mi preoccupò
era un mostro sanguinolento con la
bavosa bocca spalancata e piena di
acuminati denti storti
senti in me risuonare come un allarme e
una voce che diceva che non potevo dare
alla dottoressa un immagine tanto
orrenda che dovevo inventarmi
qualcos'altro
un fiore in sboccio disse Allora e
continuai così mentre mostri
continuavano ad apparire nelle macchie
per tutte le schede successive
sabato 23 settembre 1995 poco dopo le 10
di sera e poco dopo aver preso un brutto
pugno in faccia nell'ennesima rissa in
cui era andato a cacciarmi
raccolsi dal gancio del motorino il
grosso lucchetto che usavo per chiuderlo
tornai dalla persona da cui mi avevano
diviso una ventina di minuti prima e
glielo schiantai sulla testa con tutta
la forza che avevo
quella sesta per fortuna
era più dura di quanto chiunque
immaginasse se la cavò con un taglio di
appena 7 punti
questo D'altronde non toglie il fatto
che avevo dato quel colpo per uccidere
il 31 marzo 1997 era un lunedì di
Pasquetta ero in Versilia verso le 8 e
mezzo di mattina mentre Allegri è
famigliole spingevano i loro passeggini
sul lungomare io ero chiuso in una
discoteca imbottito di sostanze
stupefacenti
dopo aver creduto a lungo tra l'altro di
ballare con le mie cuginette di 4 anni
stavo per afferrare la testa di una
ragazza poco distante da me pensando che
fosse una bottiglia di Coca Cola su un
piedistallo di marmo
un mio amico li accanto per fortuna se
ne accorse e riuscì a fermarmi in tempo
quasi esattamente nove anni dopo il 4
marzo del 2006 sempre alle 8:30 di
mattina ero però a Milano avevo appena
fatto colazione in un bar di largo La
Foppa e prima di tornare a casa feci il
lungo giro dell'isolato
appoggiandomi al muro ogni qualche
decina di metri cercando di controllare
dei violenti conati di vomito
non ero questa volta le prese con il
residuo di qualche sostanza
No avevo appena letto due fenomenali
articoli su un mio libro uscito un paio
di settimane prima
non sarebbe stata l'ultima volta
imparai che per qualche ragione le
grandi soddisfazioni della mia vita si
accompagnano sempre a pesanti
rivoluzioni di stomaco
ora Questo sembra davvero il racconto di
un autore con poca fantasia ma
garantisco che erano davvero di nuovo le
otto e mezzo di mattina alle 8:31 per
l'esattezza quando il 23 novembre del
raccolsi dalle mani dellostetrica la mia
quarta figlia Elisabetta e la poggiai
per la prima volta in braccio a sua
madre
ed eccomi qui il primo aprile del 2023
invitato a un tetto doc
La Vita È buffa no
Questo è il Ted delle imprese
apparentemente impossibili
Beh in questo caso l'impresa
apparentemente impossibile sono io
sono state talmente violente scoscese le
salite le discese della mia vita che a
un certo punto quando inizia ad avere il
sospetto forse di venirne a capo inizi a
domandarmi cosa potesse averle causate
ma soprattutto come avevo fatto a
restare a galla in quel maremoto
a dire è vero più che domandarmelo io ho
preso la domandarmelo gli altri
e
fa da sé che la risposta è più
complicata di quanto non si riesca a
dare in questi semplici dodici minuti
Eppure
dopo aver balbettato qualche banalità su
amici famiglia fortuna
tranquillanti
Mi trovai a dare una risposta molto
precisa che finì per sorprendere anche
me
scrivere
ora bisogna ricordare che scrivere
significa sempre anche leggere quindi
racchiudo in questa semplice parola
tutti i libri che per esempio tengono il
mio studio e che hanno contribuito
ognuno a spostare anche solo di una
frazione di grado La mia percezione del
mondo
In ogni caso scrivere nel corso degli
anni era diventata Per me una attività
estremamente specifica fatta con una
certa penna un certo quaderno una certa
ora del giorno
con determinati riti che mi aiutassero a
ricostruire per così dire ogni giorno la
stessa scatola
il punto non era scrivere a mano che è
faticoso poi bisogna ricopiare al
computer che è ancora più faticoso o con
quel quaderno che trovo solo in America
o a quell'ora del giorno che mi obbliga
ad andare a letto con le galline a
svegliarmi a buio quando preferirei
qualche volta a vedermi un bel film La
sera E che ne so la mattina bermi almeno
un caffè guardando l'alba ecco
Il punto è che tutti quegli elementi
contribuivano a farmi entrare in un
particolare stato della mente
in cui immagini e parole finivano per
sorprendere anche me stesso
ero
sono là dentro una versione migliore di
me e questo aiuta ad acquietare a
riorganizzare anche il resto della
giornata
un giorno nel libro divulgativo di un
professore di psicologia che ha passato
l'intera sua vita a domandarsi come mai
alcune persone stanno meglio di altre
lessi questa
apparentemente banale frase
la forma e il contenuto della vita
dipendono da come si adopera
l'attenzione
tutto qui la somma è di 30 anni di studi
lei avevo già letto abbastanza di
neuroscienze e psicologia per sapere che
il nostro cervello è in grado di
elaborare soltanto una certa quantità di
informazioni alla volta
quello che questo buffo professore di
origini ungheresi cresciuto a Roma tra
l'altro dal nome impossibile micalici
zemali aveva scoperto che la qualità
della nostra esistenza è data da
l'efficacia con cui orientiamo il fuoco
limitato della nostra attenzione
sono tanti altri grandi meriti di
shigemicali uno Aveva sdoganato nel
proprio campo il concetto di entropia
e soprattutto aver scoperto lo stato a
più bassa entropia della mente umana
Ora non so se tutti qui sono a loro agio
con il termine di entropia ma volendo
riassumere e semplificarlo è la quantità
di dispersione di energia di un sistema
Cioè per intendersi la differenza
sostanziale tra il motore di una Panda
il motore di una macchina da corsa di
fari cilindrata è che il secondo è
costruito con materiali e una precisione
tali da fargli trasformare più energia
termica in energia cinetica
Ecco noi apparentemente non siamo fatti
in maniera tanto diversa
cioè Alcuni di noi attraverso
l'addensamento della loro attenzione
riescono a immagazzinare meglio le
informazioni a trasformarle in azioni
più efficaci
e questo non soltanto le rende più
produttive ma anche più serene
e il trucco il marchingegno fondamentale
con cui riescono in questo piccolo
miracolo quotidiano è un particolare
stato della mente che descrivono tutti
in maniera un po' diversa ma in cui
risuona continuamente l'immagine di un
flusso e così ci gemicali decise di
chiamarlo
Flow
precisamente aveva iniziato la sua lunga
e fortunata carriera occupandosi di
creatività e avrebbe continuato a
studiarla per tutta la vita perché aveva
il sospetto all'inizio avrebbe
confermato poi che
l'applicazione aperta sistematica in
divisa della nostra attenzione a un
dominio simbolico fosse una delle strade
più utili verso una qualche forma di
felicità
e anche il segreto dei più grandi
traguardi dell'essere umano
Beh io sono una delle prove viventi che
aveva ragione
ma soprattutto che se ce l'ho fatta io
ce la può fare davvero chiunque Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]